RELEASE, ELIMINATING SANCTUARY
CITIES AND RESTORING THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY.
BRIAN BABBIN IS JOINING US.
I WANT TO GO DOWN YOUR LIST.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO WITH
CATCH AND RELEASE?
>> WELL, WE WANT TO REINSTATE
THE NOT CATCH AND RELEASE.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT’S
HAPPENING.
I’VE BEEN LISTENING TO YOUR SHOW
HERE FOR THE LAST FEW MINUTES
AND INCREDIBLY JEN PSAKI AT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING THAT THE
BORDER IS CLOSED.
IT’S FAR FROM CLOSED.
IF IT’S CLOSED, I’D HATE TO SEE
WHAT SHE THINKS OPEN IS.
BECAUSE WITH ALL THE REVERSAL OF
THE POLICIES OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S ADMINISTRATION BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION, IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CREATED AN ENORMOUS CRISIS DOWN
THERE AND THAT’S WHY WE’RE
TAKING A NUMBER OF MEMBERS OF
THE TEXAS HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, U.S. HOUSE, AND
WE’VE ALSO -- I’D LIKE TO SAY
THIS TOO, ARTHEL.
WE HAVE INVITED VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS TO ATTEND SOME OF
OUR ITINERARY AND SEE FOR
HERSELF SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN
HADS GIVEN HER THE DIRECTION OF
THE BORDER, WE THOUGHT IT WOULD
BE A GOOD THING TO DO FOR HER TO
COME DOWN AND SEE EXACTLY WHAT’S
GOING ON DOWN THERE SINCE IN THE
PAST SHE HAS THOUGHT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S POLICIES WERE
CRUEL AND INHUMANE AND THEY WERE
PUTTING CHILDREN IN CAGES AND
QUITE FRANKLY IT’S GOING ON AT A
MUCH, MUCH WORSE RATE TODAY.
ARTHEL:  SO A COUPLE OF THINGS,
CONGRESSMAN.
I HEAR WHAT YOU’RE TELLING ME.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT.
WHAT HAS THE VICE PRESIDENT’S
OFFICE TOLD YOU?
IS VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS GOING
TO GO DOWN WITH YOU OR WHAT’S
THE PLAN?
>> WE HAVE NOT HEARD YET BUT
WE’RE HOPING SO.
WE’LL BE GOING DOWN THERE
TONIGHT AND SOME OF US WILL BE
GOING DOWN THERE TOMORROW.
QUITE FRANKLY, EVEN PRESIDENT
LOPEZ OVERDOOR SAID PRESIDENT PR
BIDEN IS THE MIGRANT PRESIDENT.
HE CREATED THIS.
HE WANTS TO TURN OUR COUNTRY
INTO A SANCTUARY COUNTRY.
ARTHEL:  I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
APPARENTLY YOU’VE HAD DIRECT
CONTACT WITH PRESIDENT OVERDOOR.
WHAT IS HE SAYING SPECIFICALLY
IN THAT, HOW PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
CAUSING THIS.
GIVE US SPECIFICS.
I’D LIKE TO KNOW, SIR.
>> YOU BET.
I HAVE NOT ACTUALLY SPOKEN WITH
PRESIDENT LOPEZ OVERDOOR.
I HAVE SPOKEN WITH MY COLLEAGUE,
DEMOCRAT HENRY CUELLAR IN LA LOR
RAY DOUGH.
WE WILL -- LOREDO.
WE WILL MEET WITH HIM IN HIS
DISTRICT.
THERE ARE QUOTES SAYING THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN ENABLED AND
EMPOWERED THE CARTELS AND HE
ACTUALLY CALLED PRESIDENT BIDEN
THE MIGRANT PRESIDENT.
ARTHEL:  DO YOU THINK TO THAT
POINT THAT THE PRESIDENT OF
MEXICO WILL WANT TO WORK WITH
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO REINSTATE THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY?
>> I WOULD HOPE SO BECAUSE IT
HAS CREATED NOT ONLY CHAOS IN
OUR COUNTRY, IT HAS CREATED
EXTREMELY BAD ENVIRONMENT FOR
HIS OWN AND I’M GOING TO COMMEND
PRESIDENT LOPEZ OVEROR BECAUSE
HE NEGOTIATED WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO SEND HIS OWN NATIONAL
GUARD AT HIS OWN SOUTHERN BORDER
WHICH HAS HELPED US.
AND IF THE BILL THAT YOU SPOKE
OF THAT I’M CO-SPONSORING, WHAT
WE NEED TO DO, WHAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN NEEDS TO DO IS END CATCH
AND RELEASE, BUILD THE WALL IN
THE SANG QUERY -- SANG SANG CANT
CITIES AND ALLOW OUR NATION
SENATE GUARD TO GO DOWN THERE
AND HELP THE HOMELAND BY
BOLSTERING THE BORDER PATROL’S
MAN POWER.
ARTHEL:  WHAT YOU’RE SAYING
BOUTS YOUR SUGGESTIONS TO SECURE
THE BORDER, THEY ALL SEEM TO BE
REASONABLE.
SO HAVE YOU -- NOW I ASKED ABOUT
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS.
I’M GOING TO ASK ABOUT PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO GET A
MEETING WITH HIM OR GET SOME OF
YOUR DELEGATION TO MEET WITH
SOMEONE IN HIS OFFICE, YOUR
PEOPLE MEET WITH HIS PEOPLE, IN
OTHER WORDS.
>> WE HAVE HAD NUMBERS.
AS YOU MENTIONED, I’M THE
CO-CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE BORDER
SECURITY CAUCUS.
WE TALKED SEVERAL TIMES, ASKING
FOR MEETINGS WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION, LIKE WE DID
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
WE WORKED HAND IN GLOVE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE PAST.
ARTHEL:  HAVE YOU GOTTEN A YES
FROM THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
YOUR REQUEST FOR A MEETING YET?
>> NO, WE HAVE NOT.
WE’VE HEARD FROM VICE PRESIDENT
KAMALA HARRIS.
BUT THEY NEED TO SEE EXACTLY
WHAT’S GOING ON.
WE HAD OUR SEC TOSSER SENATORS D
LAST WEEK.
WE’RE GOING TO SEE THE SAME
THING.
IT GETS WORSE BY THE DAY.
ARTHEL:  IT’S PROBLEMATIC FOR
SURE.
AND I WANT TO ASK YOU -- I’M
ASKING THESE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I
WANT TO JUST LIKE YOU, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS GETS --
THE PROBLEM GETS FIXED.
WHEN I ASK ABOUT THE MEETINGS,
YOU SAID YOU HAVEN’T HEARD BACK
FROM THEM YET.
DID YOU JUST -- HOW LONG AGO DID
YOU REQUEST A MEETING?
I’M ASKING IS THAT A CAN REQUEST
THAT’S BEEN LINGERING FOR 60
DAYS OR DID YOU REQUEST IT A
COUPLE DAYS AGO AND YOU’RE
WAITING TO HEAR BACK.
>> NO, IT’S BEEN SEVERAL DAYS
AGO.
WE’RE WAITING TO HEAR BACK FROM
THEM.
AND THIS -- WE’VE BEEN TOLD FOR
DAY AFTER DAY, WEEK AFTER WEEK,
THAT THIS IS NOT A CRISIS AND
YET WE KNOW THAT IT IS A CRISIS.
SO THIS IS TIME FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO STEP UP AND
SEE IT FOR THEMSELVES.
AND NOT PUT UNOFFICIAL GAG
ORDERS SO THE MEDIA CAN’T GO
DOWN AND SEE THE FACILITIES AND
TELL US THAT WE HAVE A CLOSED
BORDER AND PEOPLE ARE BEING
TURNED BACK WHEN WE KNOW THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT THE TRUTH.
ARTHEL:  THERE DEFINITELY NEEDS
TO BE TRANSPARENCY.
THE MEDIA SHOULD BE ALLOWED IN
SO WE CAN SHOW THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC WHAT’S GOING ON AND
CONGRESSMAN, YOU SEEM TO HAVE
GREAT COMPASSION OR PASSION I
SHOULD SAY BEHIND YOUR FIGHT TO
SECURE THE BORDER SO I’M HOPING
THAT YOU WILL GETS ACCESS TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND TO VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS AND THAT
SOMEHOW IN A BIPARTISAN WAY WE
CAN WORK TO FIX THE PROBLEM DOWN
THERE.
>> ABSOLUTELY, ARTHEL.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT NOT ONLY THE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY BUT PROTECT
THESE MIGRANTS.
THEY HAVE BEEN LURED UP HERE BY
RHETORIC FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHICH HAS OPENED
THIS BORDER AND ENDANGERS
EVERYONE INCLUDING THEMSELVES.
ARTHEL:  CONGRESSMAN, WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THIS SUNDAY.